[Musique]
récemment le prix Nobel de physique a
été décerné à trois chercheurs pour
leurs travaux sur l'enchevêtrement
quantique ils ont démontré l'exactitude
de ce mystérieux concept comme il
explique ma collègue Bouchra wati
le monde de la physique
des règles qui peuvent paraître étranges
par exemple des objets peuvent avoir
deux caractéristiques opposées en même
temps
ou encore il semble communiquer
instantanément comme par télépathie
[Musique]
c'est ce que l'on observe dans le
phénomène de l'enchevêtrement quantique
aussi appelé intrication quantique la
démonstration de ce phénomène a été
récompensé en 2022 par le prix Nobel de
physique
pour comprendre de quoi il s'agit
imaginons deux amis alice et Bob
alice et Bob se retrouvent devant une
paire de boîtes qui contiennent chacune
une balle l'une rouge et l'autre bleu
mais pour l'instant ils ignorent la
couleur de la balle qui se trouve dans
leur boîte ils prennent chacun une boîte
puis il monte à bord d'une fusée et il
part dans des directions opposées vers
des planètes situées à une année-lumière
l'une de l'autre cela signifie que la
lumière prend un an pour se rendre de la
planète où se trouve Alice à celle où se
trouve Bob une fois à destination Alice
ouvre sa boîte et découvre une balle
rouge puis Bob ouvre la sienne et
découvre une balle bleue jusque là rien
de surprenant
mais selon la physique quantique les
balles n'étaient ni rouge ni bleu tant
que les boîtes étaient fermées elles
avaient les deux couleurs en même temps
c'est ce que l'on appelle la
superposition quantique
ouvre sa boîte que la balle décide en
quelque sorte de sa couleur soit rouge
soit bleu et au même moment la balle de
Bob prend automatiquement l'autre
couleur puisqu'il n'y a qu'une seule
balle de chaque couleur mais il y a un
hic selon la théorie de la relativité
d'Albert Einstein rien ne peut voyager
plus vite que la lumière
puisqu'à lisse et Bob sont à une
année-lumière l'un de l'autre toute
communication entre eux prendraient au
moins un an à être transmise pourtant la
balle de Bob réagit instantanément
lorsque la balle d'aller adopte sa
couleur pour Einstein cela était
impossible pourtant dans le monde
quantique c'est bien ce qui se produit
les balles d'Alice et de Bob sont dites
enchevêtrés ou intriquée elles sont
corrélées de sorte que peu importe où
elle se trouve dans l'univers la couleur
de l'une détermine la couleur de l'autre
sans qu'elle ne communique entre elles
en physique quantique il ne s'agit pas
de balle de couleur mais de particules
comme des photons ou des électrons par
exemple deux photons émis par des
faisceaux laser peuvent être intrigués
de sorte que les propriétés mesurées sur
un photon influence instantanément les
propriétés de l'autre pendant des
décennies des physiciens étaient
sceptiques et proposaient d'autres
explications pour ce phénomène
par exemple peut-être que les balles
d'Alice et de Bob possédaient déjà une
couleur au moment d'être placée dans
leur boîte ou peut-être que cette
corrélation n'était qu'une coïncidence
mais dans les dernières décennies les
physiciens Alain aspects John closer et
Anton zellinger ont chacun mené des
expériences sur des photons intriquées
[Musique]
ils ont démontré hors de tout doutes que
les autres hypothèses étaient fausses et
que l'intrication quantique était bel et
bien réelle c'est ce qui leur a valu le
prix Nobel de physique
ce phénomène étrange a aujourd'hui des
applications technologiques bien
concrètes par exemple la cryptographie
quantique en utilisant des particules
intriquées pour transmettre de
l'information confidentielle on peut
savoir si quelqu'un tente d'intercepter
le message puisque tout interférence sur
une particule de la paire intriquée sera
immédiatement visible sur sa particule
jumelle
d'autres chercheurs utilisent
l'intrication quantique pour développer
des ordinateurs plus puissants
ou encore des microscopes à très haute
résolution
bien que les lois de la physique
quantique semblent encore aujourd'hui un
peu mystérieux elle nous permet déjà de
dépasser les limites de la technologie